>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Martin Baron: Hello everybody.
My name is Marty Baron.
I'm the executive editor
of the Washington Post.
The Washington Post has
been a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival
since beginning and we're happy
to do it again this year.
The Library of Congress has
been the festival's host
since the festival
began 16 years ago.
And we want to thank the chairman
of the festival David Rubenstein
and the many National
Book Festival's sponsors
who made the event
possible this year.
You can make a donation to this--
the festival by checking the
information in your program.
There is going to be time for
questions after we're all done
and this is being filmed as
well so you should know that.
So, to our speaker.
The Washington Post is
gratified to have some
of the finest national security
reporters in the country.
And a standout among
them is Joby Warrick.
When you read "Black Flags: The
Rise of ISIS", you will see why.
There's Joby's seriousness of
purpose, his relentless reporting
and impressive sourcing,
how he embraces nuance while never
losing his way in complexity.
There is his eye for
revelatory detail and his talent
for commanding your attention
with the finest techniques
of storytelling.
In fact, this is such a good story
that HBO has a movie in development
with Bradley Cooper as
the executive producer.
We're hoping it will be made.
This is as the New York Times wrote
in its review, a gripping book
of novelistic energy and
the most revealing portrait
yet of Abu Musab al-Zarqawi,
founding father of the organization
that became the Islamic State.
As our country aims to
destroy ISIS and as ISIS seeks
to metastasize beyond Iraq and
Syria, there cannot be a more urgent
and timely treatment of the subject.
As ISIS and terrorism takes center
stage in a presidential race,
this book offers a
refuge in actual facts.
Imagine that.
And in an absorbing history of our
times, and in a sober assessment
of failures across the political
and governmental landscape.
For good reason, "Black Flags" this
year was awarded the Pulitzer Prize
in general nonfiction.
The judges described it as a
brilliant and definitive history
that reveals the long arc of today's
most dangerous extremist threat.
All of us at the Post
were enormously proud
when the Pulitzer board recognized
the excellence of Joby's work.
And it was not, by the way,
the first time they've done so.
The prize for "Black Flags"
is Joby's second Pulitzer.
He previously won in 1996
for a series of articles
about the environmental costs
of North Carolina's hog farming
industry written with two colleagues
at the News and Observer
Newspaper in Raleigh.
So you can see his range.
In the two decades since
that book, since that work,
Joby has been a cherished
colleague at the Post.
He is as soft spoken and
gracious as he is diligent,
determined, and dedicated.
So not just a superb reporter
but also a wonderful human being.
It's a real pleasure and honor
to introduce Joby Warrick.
[ Applause ]
>> Joby Warrick: Well,
Marty, thanks a lot for that.
It is a pleasure to be
with you and it is an honor
to be introduced by my boss.
I've been at the Post just
as Marty said for 20 years.
I've worked for some legendary
editors from the Bradlees,
of course the Graham family.
And I could tell you
the Post has never been
in better hands right
than it is right now.
And the fact that we
here in Washington--
[ Applause ]
And I know, you know, you must
get mad at us at least once a day.
And I mean, that's
part of our job too.
But the fact that we have a
quality newspaper of the caliber
of the Washington Post that it
continues to be so ambitious
and so energetic, and
just so committed
to its mission is a reflection
of the people at the top.
So I feel privileged to work for
Marty and I think you're all be kind
of grateful to be in a
town and in a country
that has editors like Marty Baron.
So thank you again for
those words, Marty.
[ Applause ]
You know, book festivals--
And I've--
doing my paperback tour
now so I'm used to this
but they said typically authors
will tell charming anecdotes
and funny stories and I
wrote a book about ISIS.
So the material doesn't really lend
itself to funny, witty stories.
But the topic is important
and I think you all know that
and perhaps it's why you're here.
And so you know, when I
do travel to a country,
people are confused
about this organization.
They are afraid and of
course they're afraid.
I think our political leaders are
very confused right now just based
on the rhetoric on
the campaign trail.
So, really my purpose in doing
this book was to bring clarity
and that's what I think that I--
That's my special gift
as a journalist,
is I try to help take
complicated stories
and make people understand
what they're really about.
So that was what I tried to do here
in the book and it's what I'm going
to try to do very briefly today.
I'm going to show some
pictures, we're going to start
with a little video photo montage
which is essentially boiling
down the history of
ISIS to three minutes.
So this is kind of a summary, after
this is over, we're going to talk
about some characters behind ISIS
but this is my little
video introduction.
It's a-- It's ISIS so it's
dark, it's not the Goth Channel
but it's a-- but it's not that
you haven't seen before I think.
So this is our little preview
of our discussion today.
I hope you can all
read the subtitles.
[ Gunshots ]
[ Foreign Language ]
So, my book "Black Flags" as I try
to explain is a story of origins.
It's a character sketch digging
into the histories of
the men behind ISIS.
And I'm going to talk about five
personalities very briefly today
starting with Zarqawi, the man
who's probably the most important
and most innovative terrorist
personality the last two decades,
second only to Osama bin Laden.
And continuing on to some other
individuals who may not be
as familiar to us but important to
understanding what we're up against.
So we start with Zarqawi,
the godfather or the founder
because he really pioneered almost
all the tactics we see ISIS using
today including the
beheadings of young men
in orange jumpsuits splashed
all over the internet.
He was an original
and dispensable force.
ISIS literally could
not exist without him.
And in a strange way as you'll see,
Zarqawi could not have
existed without us.
So let's understand him as
a way to get into our topic.
Every terrorist starts out life
as a kid, a cute little kid.
And here he is in 1968 with
his mom in Amman, Jordan.
And the thing is he
wasn't a cute kid,
he was a bad seed from
the very beginning.
He was in constant trouble from
the time of middle school onward,
not just Tom Sawyer mischief
but cutting kids with razors,
using drugs, he drank, he was a
violent vicious youth absolutely
headed for trouble.
And by the time he was a teenager,
he was a high school dropout,
he had tattoos, anything
but a religious guy,
extensive criminal record.
Then he gets a bit of
a religious conviction
and then even more importantly like
many other young in his region,
he decides in the late
1990s to go fight jihad,
and that means going to Afghanistan.
And this is really the cradle
of the modern Jihadist movement,
this is where we get
Al-Qaeda and so many
of the groups we're
familiar with today.
Well, he goes to Afghanistan,
he fails even there
because he arrives too
late to fight the Soviets.
They've already gone home.
But he joins the Arab army, he gets
involved in the civil war there
and then this violent young
man discovers surprisingly
that he's really good at one
thing, which is killing people.
He's a ferocious fighter and his
religious fervor is being pumped
up because he's learning at
the feet of a new generation,
the likes of Osama bin
Laden and his lieutenants.
Then the war ends for
him and he's back home.
And if you think about
the experience of a lot
of our returning veterans,
it's pretty much that way
for Zarqawi and his friends.
They don't have anything to do.
They want to try to keep this fervor
going and so they start to look
for ways to build their
own jihadist cell.
And so they're looking around.
What are they going to
do in peaceful Jordan?
Well, they start attacking
symbols of western corruption.
They go after bars and
liquor stores to get the idea
of attacking pornographic theaters
and this is a great moment for them.
They send a guy into
a porno house in Amman
with a bomb to blow the place up.
The kid goes in and gets
engrossed in the movie.
He forgets all about the bomb
which then blows up at his feet.
He loses both his legs
and nobody else gets hurt.
But these are kinds of knuckleheads
that we're dealing with here
in the late-- in the early 1990s.
Well, the Jordanians obviously
get tired of these guys.
This is a, you know,
it's a problem for them.
So they lock a bunch of them up.
They lock up Zarqawi.
They lock up a lot of his
followers and these guys, you know,
who went off to war at
Afghanistan are trying
to be contained and
corralled in prison.
But in jail, they end up being
kind of corralled together
because the Jordanians
are afraid if they were
with the general population,
they'll start to infect other people
so they're off by themselves,
about 50 of them in one cell.
And this becomes kind
of the jihadi university
where they sort of
egg each other on.
They share ideology.
They talk about tactics.
It turns out to be not a very good
thing and now at this environment,
Zarqawi emerges as a very
charismatic and capable leader.
Well here's where Zarqawi gets
a couple of incredible breaks.
He's supposed to be sentenced
in prison for 15 years, so 2009.
He spent all those years in jail.
We never would have heard of him.
But in 1999, something happens.
The King of Jordan dies and there's
a tradition of amnesty in Jordan.
If a king dies then
there's a general amnesty
for political prisoners.
So parliament comes up with a
list of people to be pardoned.
You know, the tribes come up with
their own list and then, you know,
about 2000 people end up getting
freed and among them is Zarqawi
and his entire band of followers
and out they go in 1999,
10 years ahead of schedule.
So as Zarqawi goes off to the
place that he loves the most,
which is Afghanistan,
and tries to unite
with Osama bin Laden, his hero.
Well, it turns out that bin Laden
wants nothing to do with him
because even for bin Laden,
even for the mastermind of 9/11,
this young kid, this hothead who
doesn't know much about Islam,
he doesn't really-- He's
not very smart it seems.
He's very violent.
He's very crude.
He's too bad even for Al-Qaeda.
So they reject him.
They kick him out.
They sent him off to the
other end of Afghanistan
to start his own little thing.
So off he goes and once again,
if he had stayed out there,
we never would have heard
of Zarqawi ever again.
But then a second miracle
happens for Zarqawi.
In February 2003, the United States
is getting ready to invade Iraq
and we're trying to make our case
to the UN and to other people
around the world about
why we want to do this.
We offered two reasons.
One is weapons of mass destruction.
We all know how that went.
The other was the possibility
that Al-Qaeda could collaborate
with these terrible Iraqi
dictator, Saddam Hussein.
If there's some kind of
collusion between the two,
they can be even more dangerous.
So this is the pitch
we make to the UN.
Well, when Colin Powell is making
his speech, he's talking about this
and who does he cite as the
prime example of this problem
but our friend Zarqawi at
the top of the list there.
Zarqawi just based on circumstantial
evidence seems to be the right guy.
He's in Iraq at the time.
He's living in the border
area between Iraq and Iran.
He's had contact with Al-Qaeda in
the past so he seems like this kind
of perfect poster child for this
problem that the US is describing.
And so, this is the
case that's made.
It turns out that entirely untrue.
There was no truth to his
connection to Al-Qaeda.
He wasn't in Al-Qaeda.
He wasn't certainly working
with Saddam Hussein's government
but that one poster made
him a celebrity overnight.
So suddenly he's receiving
arms, sort of money and support,
recruits from all around the world.
He becomes sort of overnight
celebrity in the jihadist community.
He has his vision that he's
going to fight a superpower.
He thinks it's going
to be United States.
It's going to be in Iraq.
So he moves himself to
Baghdad in 2003 to wait
for the Americans to arrive.
So when he gets there, he
starts to build alliances.
Here's this crazy guy that wants
to start a terrorist movement.
Suddenly, he's got
all kinds of allies
because the Iraqi army has been
disbanded, all those colonels
and generals and majors
don't have jobs anymore
so they're looking to fight back.
You've got the Ba'athist Party.
Everybody who is a professional
in Iraq was a Ba'athist.
Suddenly all those people
are looking for leadership
and Zarqawi moves into that
fact and he becomes the nucleus
for this new insurgency that we
began to see unfolding in 2003.
He's got a good head for
strategy and he starts going
out after some very
important targets.
He goes after the UN headquarters.
He kills the leader of
the UN mission in Iraq.
He goes after NGOs, the Red
Cross, all kinds of groups
that would help the United States,
who would give us the cover
legitimacy, drives them home.
And then, more importantly,
he goes after the Sunni-Shia
divide in this country.
Sunnis and Shiites have been living
together reasonably well for decades
but Zarqawi decides very
deliberately to start a Civil War.
So he blows up their
most important mosque.
He kills their leaders and suddenly
you have appraisal killings you've
got essentially shooting back
and forth between two groups
that had gotten along
pretty good together.
So strategically, you think about
what he did, it was pretty smart.
He isolated us in Iraq then he
sets off a civil war around us
and we're-- By 2004, 2005, we're
in pretty bad shape in terms
of our occupation and
our plans for Iraq.
So, the next thing that happened,
this is kind of background noise
for Zarqawi because he's
got bigger ambitions.
He wants to become an
international star.
He feels he has a destiny.
And so he develops this notion that
no matter what kind of bombing,
what kind of shooting
you might be able to do,
there's nothing that's
more gripping,
that's more so viscerally horrible
than watching a single execution.
So he grabs a random
American off the street,
this is a kid named Nick
Berg from Philadelphia.
He takes him into his cell.
He sits him down with
an orange jumpsuit,
the image we were also familiar
with and he personally--
that's Zarqawi reading
the script there.
He personally beheads this
young man with his own hand.
This becomes his calling card.
Many beheadings will follow.
The violence that Zarqawi
unleashes just tears up the country
and it's too much even for Al-Qaeda.
And so that's not the
only difference.
Zarqawi begins to launch a new
media campaign with himself
at the center using social media
platforms just becoming available.
So he got the gray-bearded Osama bin
Laden, you know, reading his sermons
from behind a, you know,
a podium, very boring,
and then you've got this
jihadist action figure,
like a black ninja
firing his machine gun,
killing Americans with
his own hands.
Young jihadists around
the world eat this up.
And then he's brash enough to make
up his own rules because remember,
he's not even a high
school graduate.
He's not very smart but he
does understand theology
and that's liberating to him
because he doesn't bother to worry
about whether he is committing
acts that aren't very Islamic,
like targeting innocent Muslim women
and children and suicide attacks.
Then he begins to think about a
really big idea which is the idea
of restoring the ancient caliphate,
the Islamic theocratic
empire of the centuries past.
He regards himself as divinely
inspired to usher in this new age
of ultra pure Islam, driving
out western governments along
with brutally destroying everyone
else that stands in his way,
from corrupt governments to
apostate sex like the Shiites.
And this struggle would end in a
mighty battle, in an Armageddon,
in which armies of Islam would
finally defeat the armies
of Christianity as some
prophets have foretold.
This was going to be
Zarqawi's role of history.
"I am the spark," he used to say.
Well, he didn't get to see
any of it because Zarqawi was
by now republic enemy number one.
We poured vast resources
into this effort to stop him.
It took us nearly three years to
track him down but eventually,
our Intel, our ground forces special
operation teams found a formula
for defeating Zarqawi
and his network.
We find his safe house.
In 2006, we drop a
couple of bombs on it
and that's the end
of Zarqawi himself.
We start dismantling the
leadership, killing number twos
and number threes,
raiding safe houses.
And just as we're figuring
all this out,
other things happened
that are helping us.
The Iraqi Sunni tribes revolt
against Zarqawi's followers
and we have this thing
called the "Anbar Awakening".
The US troops search happens.
And by 2009, all that's left
was just a few hundred followers
who have been driven deep
underground in hiding.
Al-Qaeda in Iraq was
essentially beaten,
but not everybody thought so.
Here's our second ISIS personality.
We now know him as
Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
He's the leader of ISIS today.
In Zarqawi's time, nobody would
have pictured him as a leader.
He was in many ways
Zarqawi's opposite, a scholar,
kind of shy, kind of boring.
His family and friends remember
him as this kid that never spoke
to anyone, carried books around his
bicycle, wasn't very impressive.
He has a doctor degree
in Islamic law,
his own track to becoming
a college professor
when the US invasion
takes place in 2003.
Baghdadi joins Zarqawi's
gang because he feels obliged
as a good Muslim to
fight the infidel.
So he becomes part of this movement.
He ends up going to jail for awhile.
Once again, he has the
prison experience exposed
to these tough guys around him.
And-- but-- then he gets-- he starts
to rise up to the ranks mostly
because other leaders around
him by 2010 are getting killed.
And so in 2010, the leaders
of this battered organization,
mostly former Iraqi army
officers by this time,
decide they need a
different kind of figurehead.
And so they pick this guy Baghdadi.
He's an Islamic scholar.
He happens to be from a tribe
that can trace his lineage back
to Muhammad, so he has serious
religious credentials to serve
as the head of the group that's
no longer calling itself Al-Qaeda
in Iraq.
It started to call itself a
state, the Islamic state of Iraq.
The state part is kind of a
joke because even to these guys,
they know there's no real state.
One of the leaders [inaudible]
reacts famously to this new name
with derision, "Where is the
state you're talking about?
We're leaving in a desert."
But history intervenes
again in ISIS's favor.
Just as Baghdadi is coming to
power, US troops are leaving Iraq
under agreement structure
in the Bush administration.
And as soon as they're gone, the
Shiite government feels emboldened
to start settling old
scores with Sunni tribes,
arresting their leaders,
kicking out Sunni army officers.
And so much of the Sunni
population begins to rebel
against the Baghdadi government,
finding more interest in common
with Zarqawi's people, with ISIS,
then with their own government.
And then a year later,
the Civil War breaks
out in Syria as we all well know.
And this is a pivotal moment
because it's an opportunity
for these guys to start
something new.
They start their own
militia group inside Syria.
They have a perfect incubator
now with a lawless state washed
in violence and weapons,
and they have a new cause,
fighting an oppressive dictator,
Assad, a man who's stirring
up passions all over
the Islamic world
by slaughtering Sunni
Arab civilians.
They renamed themselves yet again
and now they're Islamic state
of Iraq and al-Sham or ISIS and
they're extraordinarily accessible
and almost immediately because
they're battle-hardened,
they're the best fighters in
the rebel side and they start
to attract foreign
recruits by the thousands.
By 2014, they're ready to break out
and they do so in dramatic fashion,
capturing the eastern half
of Syria then invading Iraq
to declare the establishment
of this Islamic caliphate.
By the summer of 2014, they're
a powerhouse, 30,000 strong,
able to conquer major Iraqi
cities, overrun entire divisions
of US trained Iraqi troops.
This is the ISIS we're
so familiar with today.
And they're also very rich
because after capturing Mosul,
they said they have
become the wealthiest
and best armed terrorist
group of all time.
They own oil wells.
They own banks, universities,
hundreds of millions
of dollars in hard currency.
These are resources the Al-Qaeda
would have only dreamed of having.
And-- but really, beyond
their wealth,
it's Zarqawi's old organization.
Zarqawi embraced violence
for its own sake.
These guys do the same
thing on a grander scale.
They also have this boldness
to reinterpret Islam in
any way they want to.
As-- Baghdadi is a religious
scholar so he goes out of his way
to create theological arguments to
justify whatever atrocity they do.
There's always a verse in the Quran
or a tradition in the hadith text
that can be made to justify--
make themselves appear to be pious
Muslims instead of just barbarians.
And just as Zarqawi understood
that the horror can be amplified
on a massive scale using the
internet, ISIS did the same
and just got better at it.
They're extremely skilled in
harnessing the power of social media
for recruitment, for screening,
for indoctrination, for training,
all of which can be done
at a distance before the recruit
even sets foot in Syrian soil.
But now instead of the shaky
handheld videos that Zarqawi used
to use, they have teams of
professional, videographers,
editors, graphic artists, working on
products aimed at young men who grew
up on army like video
games, like Call of Duty.
This formula works and the idea of
ISIS becomes a powerful attraction.
Thirty-five thousand foreigners
travel to the caliphate
to join this army, far surpassing
the number of foreign fighters
who joined Al-Qaeda and
Afghanistan or Zarqawi's Iraqi army.
The movement metastasizes.
In a year, there are nine mini
states of ISIS around the world
in cells and dozens of places
including about 5000 ISIS recruits
from Europe alone,
which brings us quickly
to our next personality
that defines ISIS today.
You may not recognize
his name or image
but you'll remember what he did.
This is Abdelhamid Abaaoud, who's
a 28-year-old Belgian national
who led the terrorist attack
in Paris last November
that killed 130 people.
His background is actually very
close to this typical prototype
of Northern Europeans who joined
ISIS, the son of Muslim immigrants
from North Africa, so
a second generation,
a troubled youth well-known
to police.
He lived in Islam made up of
middle class Muslim immigrants.
He's a kid that truly didn't
fit in in his society of--
he's not really a religious Muslim.
He's not really a modern citizen
of his family's adopted country.
He ends up being radicalized in
prison and when he joins ISIS,
he suddenly has two things he never
had before, a sense of belonging
and a cause, something that allows
this misbehaved misfit to feel
as though his life
counts for something.
He travels to Syria and
initially he's a bit distressed
by the bloodshed.
A few months later, he's
fully with the program.
He's posting videos of himself
dragging corpses behind cars.
He becomes a key coordinator
for the ISIS attack
in Paris as we all well remember.
It was the biggest and-- his
biggest and final assignment.
The two things we have to
remember about him when we think
about the story is, one, he's
emblematic of a population
that is particularly
vulnerable to ISIS's message,
nearly always second
generation, children of immigrants
who feel conflicted about their
identities and not well-integrated
in their societies,
struggling personally,
don't seem to have a sense
of purpose or future.
They're looking for
meaning and for adventure
and ISIS offers all
those things for them.
The second key thing, a
primary reason ISIS carries
out attacks abroad is it
wants young men like Abaaoud
to feel even more alienated.
The more countries feel threatened
by ISIS, the greater the tendency
to crack down on young Muslims,
to profile them, to harass them,
to make them feel even
more alienated.
How do we know this?
ISIS talks about it
in its own literature.
Just before the Paris
attack last November,
ISIS's English language magazine
puts out an article that talks
about the gray zone in Europe.
This is the zone where
millions of Muslims inhabit.
They feel conflicted about
their identity and ISIS wants
to force them to choose sides.
The article says this, "Muslims
in the west will quickly find
themselves between two choices,
either they apostatize and adopt the
infidel religion or they immigrate
to the Islamic state
and escape prosecution."
This is a binary choice for
ISIS and it welcomes our help
in driving Muslims to their corner.
For us in the west, the
solutions that seem easiest
and most politically
palpable are often the ones
that get us in a deeper hole.
Real quickly, the fourth
ISIS personality to talk
about was never really
a member of ISIS.
Yet we all associate Omar
Mateen with the Islamic state.
This is the young man who
walked into the Pulse Nightclub
in Orlando last June
and killed 49 people
in the worst mass shooting
in US history.
Mateen told police
he did it for ISIS.
Today, there's no evidence that
he had any contact with ISIS
in a serious way and in fact,
his statement suggest a very limited
grasp of ISIS's belief and ideology
and yet, ISIS gets credit
for the attack anyway
and it becomes a talking point
in our political discourse.
Here's what's interesting again
to me about Mateen's story.
It's another young man
who fits the profile
of a typical Northern
European ISIS recruit,
the son of Muslim immigrant,
second generation again.
A young man in his 20s
with a troubled background,
unable to find personal success
in his life and feeling excluded
and persecuted by the
dominant culture.
So he embraces an extremist
ideology as a way
to feel empowered and important.
Even more striking to me is that
Mateen fits another profile,
that of the typical perpetrator of
an American mass shooting event.
There's an interesting
piece actually
in today's Washington Post
that makes this point.
It notes that "Islamic extremist
like Mateen share many of these--
the same traits as regular mass
killers, if we can call them that.
Almost all our young
men who struggle to fit
in their communities, they feel
alienated and persecuted in some way
and they also have a boastfulness
and a craving for attention."
It's the same profile for
example as Dylann Roof,
the young man from South
Carolina who shot up a church
in South Carolina in Charleston
and killed nine people.
One expert in the article
makes his observation.
Omar Mateen has more in
common with Dylann Roof
than he does with Osama bin Laden.
ISIS just offers certain young
men a different kind of excuse
for carrying out their
revenge fantasies.
This is pretty dark stuff and
it's pretty depressing so I do
like to always include the fact
there are reasons to be hopeful
about our fight right now.
If you follow the news, you
know the caliphate is really
from a series of attacks.
They're losing ground about half
of what was once ISIS a territory
in Iraq is now liberated.
Liberating Iraq means fewer
resources for ISIS, fewer oil cells,
fewer towns and villages
they can exploit for cash.
So you see here in this map that
the size of caliphate is shrinking.
The area in green was once
controlled by ISIS, now it's not.
They're faltering in
the public relations war
because people see the brutality.
They see the hypocrisy.
And even young Arab
Muslims, their core audience,
are starting to turn away.
This is a look at British
Muslims who turns out.
So you see just in a year's time,
support or opposition rather
to ISIS drop from or
[inaudible] from about 65% to 85%.
It's somewhat disturbing as the
fact that this kind of small group
of people who embrace the ideology
of ISIS has remained pretty static.
Other good news, we have
more and more seeing Muslim,
other Muslim countries, Muslim
Arabs taking on a greater share
of the fight for participation
of the Arab campaign to boots
on the ground and this
makes them going slower
but it's usually important
because Arab boots
in the ground are vastly preferable
to an occupation and invasion
by outside forces for all
kinds of obvious reasons.
And it's also encouraging.
We're seeing more Muslims
take a public stand
against this extremist ideology.
One of the world's great religions
is being attacked from within
and only other Muslims have
the standing to be able
to defeat the virulence that has
affected so many young people.
We see the King of Jordan, Abdullah,
organizing an effort by hundreds
of Muslim clerics from all sects to
denounce extremist interpretation.
Egypt's President Sisi here goes
to the top of theological seminary
in Cairo to call for an Islamic
reformation, saying to his leaders,
"We have to take back our religion."
It's a hopeful start but we need
to see a lot more than this.
And finally, despite the good
news on it from the front lines,
I can't be optimistic about
defeating this ideology
in the near term and here is why.
I introduce my fifth
and final personality.
I won't use his real name but we'll
call him Ahmad [assumed spelling].
He's seven years old.
We met him in a refugee
camp in Germany.
He was one of thousands of young
children who had lived under ISIS
in towns and villages
of the caliphate.
He's a bright, beautiful
young boy who happened to live
in the Syrian city of
Raqqah when ISIS took over.
Within months, he was in the ISIS
trading camp, getting indoctrinated,
learning how to use a gun.
He was taught that his
parents were not good Muslims
and he should report
any bad behavior
at home that wasn't Islamic.
He was taught that the
greatest possible calling
for young men his age was
to be a suicide bomber.
Ahmad talked to us about
witnessing executions.
He talked to us about going to a
local park and finding the bodies
of men with their severed
heads stacked up next to them.
Every now and then during this
interview, he would shutdown and ask
for some time-out and at one point,
he asks us for a piece of paper
so he could draw a
picture of Syria, his home.
This is what he drew.
He was telling us a story about
something he'd personally witnessed.
A man with one eye on the
right side was a prisoner
who was brought into
the town square.
The man on the left has a
knife and he beheads him.
And then below, you see the one-eyed
man's head lying on the floor.
We worry in this country
about ISIS recruits,
about people being radicalized on
the internet or traveling to Iraq
or Syria to fight but we're
facing entirely different problem
with the generation of young people
who grew up under this terror.
I bring this up because when
the caliphate does collapse--
and I think we're beginning
to see the end of it--
westerners cannot afford
to look away.
We can't declare victory and
go home because the seeds
of countless tragedies
are still out there now.
Who's going to provide psychological
counseling for these young Ahmad?
Who's going to rebuild
his city and his school?
Who's going to rebuild the
economy and offer hope for a job
and a family someday in the future?
It's overwhelming to think
about the size of this task
but it's what is important
not just for moral reasons
but because of our own security.
Because if we don't find a
way to address this problem,
you can be assured that we'll
be hearing from Ahmad or boys
and girls like him in the future.
You can be confident that the kind
of extremism and the brutality
that we've witnessed in the
last two years will come back
to us again and again.
Thank you for your time.
I'm happy to take a few questions.
[ Applause ]
We've got microphones.
All right, we'll start over here.
>> Hi. Thank you for your talk.
>> Joby Warrick: Thank you.
>> While depressing,
really interesting.
>> Joby Warrick: Thanks.
>> About like several months ago,
John Kerry declared ISIS is having--
committed acts of genocide and I'm
wondering what your take on that is
because I think it's interesting
that a terrorist group
have been designated that.
I don't believe another group has.
So what the challenges does United
States has and other groups have--
other countries have
in tackling a group
that is a terrorist group
having also committed--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- human rights atrocities.
That's a really good question
and it was an unusual move.
You're right.
It's not simply typically
deal with terrorist groups.
We've never declared
Al-Qaeda to be--
>> Yeah.
>> Joby Warrick: --
guilty of genocide.
But in the case of ISIS,
it's a label that fits.
You see what's going on in the area
and there is a systematic
destruction of cultures
in our communities and societies.
It's not going to deter ISIS that
we declare them to be, you know,
perpetrators of genocide but I think
just as it's an act of a community
of nations including our
Muslim allies and friends
in the region just to call
this what it is and try
to hold them accountable
in some sort
of global way I think is a
powerful message and it just--
it's something we need to do as
opposed to something that will help
in some, you know, practical way
but I think it's really
important and interesting stuff.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Joby Warrick: Let's-- over here.
>> I noticed in the maps
you showed that it seems
as though ISIS hasn't
made it to Morocco.
Why is that?
>> Joby Warrick: To where?
>> Morocco.
>> Joby Warrick: Morocco.
Yeah. You know, some
countries like Morocco,
like Jordan too I think
is they have a problem.
They know they have local
cells and they deal with them.
Sometimes it's serious problems but
so far there hasn't been any ability
of these groups to organize in
serious way that we're aware of.
And I think it's partly
reflective of the--
some security culture
in those countries.
The Moroccans, the
Jordanians are really,
really good at their
internal security.
They're good at knowing
what people are doing.
But also just may be
an unknown factor.
I mean, every few months we see
some, you know, some disruption
of a plot in Jordan or in Morocco.
So they're definitely there, they
just don't seem to have the grip
that they do in some of
these other countries.
Good question.
>> I was wondering if
you could talk a bit more
about the financials of ISIS.
So they have access to all-- a lot
of natural resources and capital
but how are they actually able
to turn that into cash and to--
like, who do they purchase from or--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- how does all that work?
>> Joby Warrick: That's
a good question.
Interesting about ISIS is they're
much more self-sufficient in terms
of their funding than most of other
terrorist groups we've looked at.
In the very beginning,
they may have benefited
from groups throughout
the Arabs and the Gulf.
More recently, they're been
just using what's available
to them locally.
They're very good at finding oil,
selling it on the black market
and they've got partners even
in places like Turkey and Syria,
countries that are officially in
war with them but they managed
to do this black market trade.
They shake down local populations.
They've been doing that
since Zarqawi's time.
You know, taxing local civilians,
you know, collecting fines
for just almost any offense
you can imagine is a--
can be a fine that
gets collected by ISIS.
But more recently, because of their
successes in taking over territory,
they also have big
assets like bank vaults.
In Mosul what I said they have--
they were able to accommodate
something like $500 million
in hard currency, Euros, dollars.
And so essentially it's
a cash economy anyway
and suddenly they've gotten more
cash than they can possibly spend.
And to give you perspective, you
know, what they need obviously,
they need to pay their soldiers.
They need to do various things.
But to carry out terrorist
attacks abroad doesn't really cost
that much as ISIS does it.
The estimate for the
cost start to finish
for the Paris attack is
somewhere around $10,000
because they got well more enough
than to carry out attacks and that
for years to come, unfortunately.
Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> Joby, I have a sort of a personal
question but before that, you--
when you went to the slide, you
pointed out a lot of the individuals
who are just angry and, you know,
they just wanted explosives.
They just wanted to be in the press.
OK. Now, the people said, the
fellow who had dropped the--
let the bombs in New York were
not related to any of these
but he was that kind of person.
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> And so maybe this could
propagate a lot encouraging.
Now the personal question
is, are you concerned
that some crazy guy is going to
come to the Washington Post Office
and either you look at your
book as a history of ISIS
so they want to show it around or--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- they think, "Wow, this is a
great way of getting into the press
by destroying the person
who wrote the book?"
>> Joby Warrick: No.
Well, it's a good question
and it's not something
that we blithely dismiss.
You know, I've lived in
the suburbs with a family
so you do think about
things like that.
You know, Marty is a pretty big
guy so I think it's nice to work
in a pretty secure office where
we feel like nobody is going
to easily come in at least--
>> Yeah.
>> Joby Warrick: --
and do harm to us.
>> Yeah.
>> Joby Warrick: My-- The one thing
and maybe this is sort of vain
or are just, you know, overly
optimistic but I always assume that,
hey, they like publicity
in some bizarre way,
and secondly there is many more
important attractive targets
than a journalist from
the Washington Post.
So I do-- very, very careful when
I'm going to travel to the region--
>> Yeah.
>> Joby Warrick: -- and otherwise,
I just try to keep my eyes open
and then do take sort of a casual
review of the line of people waiting
to get their book signed and make
sure nobody is carrying anything
that looks--
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Joby Warrick: -- that
looks like a weapon but yeah,
it's just not an idle thought.
Thank you for the question.
>> Yeah. But again,
looking at your book,
it's the history of the program.
So people in ISIS can
show it around to people--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- because you've
documented their heroes.
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah, that is true.
And the book, because of the
Pulitzer, it's coming out in a lot
of languages including Arabic.
So that's something I think about.
Thank you.
>> I want to ask a
question as a journalist
who really admires what you do and
really appreciates the craft and--
>> Joby Warrick: Thank you.
>> -- believe that your book
ranks with "The Looming Towers",
an outstanding piece of
nonfiction narrative.
And it's a craft question,
how did you--
it sounds like you stored it
with some intelligence agents
presumably off the record in Jordan.
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> That's my guess.
You don't have to describe your
sources, but how did you, A,
get access to them and
then B, get them to open up
and then widen your net to
people had been inside the ISIS
organization where it's--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- an astounding
piece of reporting?
>> Joby Warrick: Well, I
appreciate that and I thank you
for the reference to Lawrence
Wright's book which is he is one
of my heroes and if I-- I'm
in the same sentence
with him, I'm flattered.
So I appreciate that.
It is a difficult challenge.
A part of what I think
held me was the fact
that I've been doing this for-- at
the Washington Post for a long time.
So for a while, over time,
you build up relationships
with intelligence people and
that's-- it's not a hard--
that's not an easy thing to
develop and not just, you know,
in this country with our agencies
but the ones overseas who's going
to travel to the region quite a bit.
I ended up getting remarkably strong
responses when I approach people
in these governments about
telling the Zarqawi story,
telling the background of ISIS
because this is an
important subject for them.
They feel like it needs
to be understood and some
of these particular
individuals were some to have--
I used their [inaudible]
names, their Arab names
but not their real names
for obvious reasons.
But once they got into it, they
were just thrilled to talk to me
and I had, you know, hours and hours
and hours of conversation with guys
who had never spoken to
another reporter but they just--
were just blown away by getting
a chance to share their knowledge
and to tell stories that were so
meaningful and important to them.
And because, I guess one
of my gifts as a journalist
if I have some is just
that I'm approachable
and I don't have an agenda
and I just want to know
and I think I come across that way.
And if you just really want
to know the facts, you know,
people can be surprisingly
cooperative in that regard.
So I think I just gotten
lucky there.
But--
>> Well, thank you very much.
One quick follow-up.
>> Joby Warrick: Sure.
>> Did the king of
Jordan cooperative
with you in one way or another?
>> Joby Warrick: Is he watching?
I have to say, this
is my second book
and the first one was also
had a Jordanian theme.
And one of the readers
of the book and someone
who admired it was
the king of Jordan.
He actually read the book
and he commented on it.
And, so I felt a little bit more
emboldened when it was the time
to write this book to ask him
and his government, you know,
I'm going to tell a story.
It's very personal to Jordan.
Extremely helpful and I just, you
know, at that, it's always better
than having a door slammed in your
face to have doors open for you.
It's like--
>> Yeah, it helps that the
king of Jordan is cooperating.
>> Joby Warrick: He kind of
pulled some strings over there.
So--
>> But thank you so much.
>> Joby Warrick: Thank you.
>> It's really a masterpiece--
>> Joby Warrick: I
enjoyed your question.
>> -- that will last for ages.
>> Joby Warrick: Thank you.
>> It's astounding.
>> Joby Warrick: How are we doing?
Well, we got a few minutes?
OK, three minutes but two
quick questions and I'm sorry,
we'll have to take
them later afterward.
>> This will be quick.
>> Joby Warrick: Sure.
>> Can you get to explain the
point of terminology, please?
You speak of ISIS.
I heard some officials including
the president speak of ISIL.
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> And then in addition, I've
heard others used the term dash.
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> Could you explain
those three, please?
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
If I could get away with using
dash and people knew what I meant
and I was not just
talking about Morse code
or something, they--
I would use that.
And the reason is, it
really all boils down to--
an attempt to transliterate Arabic,
which doesn't always happen easily.
So what ISIS calls itself is
now just the Islamic State
but it's the Islamic
State of Iraq and al-Sham.
It sounds like an S for the
second S in the abbreviation,
which might be Syria, but
it's not really Syria.
Sham is this big region,
essentially ignoring history
of the last century, ignoring
countries that were created
like Syria, Jordan and Israel
that didn't exist 110 years ago,
and just lumping it together in
this ancient place called Sham.
And so when you hear ISIS,
people are saying Sham.
If you're ISIL people
are saying Levant
which is essentially the English
term that translates to al-Sham.
And so that's people call it ISIL.
So I'm not trying to be
clever or cute or trying
to be politically correct.
It's really just a struggle
to figure out a proper way
to transliterate the words.
But, thank you for that.
>> Thank you.
>> Joby Warrick: Let's do one more.
>> Hello, sir.
>> Joby Warrick: Hi.
>> My question is, what role if
any do you feel that our media
and in Europe play in creating an
atmosphere that makes it easier
for groups like ISIS to recruit in--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- places like, you know, Orlando
where, you know, that man was--
>> Joby Warrick: Yeah.
>> -- very familiar with ISIS and
Western Europe and Northern Europe?
>> Joby Warrick: That's a good
question and it's something
that we wrestle with
at the Washington Post
and on up to Marty's level.
It's-- We do take very
seriously the fact
that our words sometimes can agitate
and excite as well as inform.
And so we do try to be restrained.
I mean, there's all kinds of,
like, we're having a discussion
about an article we're trying to put
together now that involves videos.
How much do you show?
We need to show enough to be able
to help people understand the
situation, not enough to be kind
of gratuitously, you know,
pruriently, you know, obscene really
with the level of violence.
But what I do feel now that we
have an important role to play
and it's this, ISIS is being--
They're losing ground
at propaganda war
because people are understanding
now what they're really about.
They might see these slick videos
that you get on the internet
but the people coming out of Raqqah,
the people who are fleeing
those countries had been abused
and just see these
people as barbarians
who are anything but Islamic.
The more we can tell those
stories and set people straight
about what ISIS is really about
destroy their own mythology.
I think that's a great
contribution to their defeat
and I don't mind saying that.
>> All right.
>> Joby Warrick: I'm sorry
we didn't get everybody,
do you want to get this last one or
two or should we just call it up?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
OK. So we're going to
pull the [inaudible].
But I encourage you
guys to come and find me
and I'm happy to talk
to both of you.
Thank you so much for your time.
It's an honor to speak with you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.